I had it 22 going into the fifth so my
question would be who do you give the
fifth round to not a lot of action then
a minute 30 left Chef chenko throws his
stupid spinning kick gets taken down Gro
has her back almost submits her finishes
the round on her back okay that's
Grasso's round my favorite part of the
whole night I think the language bear
issue Gro they put the belt on she's
like yeah and DC who I absolutely love
DC's like uh so how'd you feel you know
you you retain the belt but you know it
it was a draw and you know did you feel
good and you know what's it feel like to
find uh Mexican Independence Day and
she's like I feel good I I won the fight
I won the fight he's like you didn't it
was a draw but uh how you feeling about
and I think she because you know they
put the belt around her and she was like
I won he's like well no it was a draw
but yeah you retain your belt so I think
she got to the back and like no you
didn't win it was a draw